welcome back to drew's news next step
american icon william shatner is about
to boldly go where no 90 year old man
has gone before
i don't think that has anything to do
with star trek that's just my weird
like line reading no wonder i didn't get
those jobs
people reports tomorrow captain kirk is
actually going into space
for reals shatner will be launched into
the stratosphere on jeff bezos's blue
origin rocket that looks so much like
something else
come on
does nobody think that looking at this
am i the only one
does it have to be that shape no
now that you mention it hi
sorry
suddenly i want to go into space
[Applause]
i was saying i've seen other craps that
have traveled to space and they don't
look like that
anyway
um this makes william shatner the oldest
person to go to space um ross would you
want to go to space i would yeah i mean
i would totally want to go to space
hello yeah i got enough frequent flyer
miles i could probably make it but i'll
tell you 90 years old and he's gonna
orbit the earth when i'm 90 i hope i can
walk around a bed bath and beyond i mean
that think about that 90 years old and
he's still saying yes to adventure that
is goals that
what
is
you ruby would you want to be shot up in
a big rocket to space drew i would not i
would not i would rather keep my feet on
the ground stay on earth there's too
much of the unknown out there i'd get
lost i anxious no thanks
are you worried you'd get like stuck in
space like uh apollo 13 or something
because come with me i promise you i'd
be like my gave her i'd get us home i'd
fix it
what how have i never heard that one
before but i don't know i just i just
said it oh my god yeah
i promise you give me a high heel and a
roll of duct tape i'm getting that ship
home honey
i'm there i'm there
i'm i'm so uh no i don't think at this
point you know maybe when it becomes
more commonplace ubiquitous and sort of
you know standard practice
show of hands who would jump on bezos's
rocket
sorry
i can't help it
i'm sorry you can't look at that rocket
and like not
it's like everybody's thinking it yeah
i'm just the person willing to say it
out loud
yeah i i don't really have you know i
heard that there's like actually
scuttlebutt um about the russians
are trying to get to space to make a
movie has anyone heard about this
you're clapping your hands what do you
know so yes they sent up an actress and
a producer
yesterday into space to be able to shoot
on the international space station and
actually have a real movie filled in
space and it's supposed to be
about a surgeon who goes up to save an
astronaut
wow
what is your name my name is susa thank
you so much well thank you thank you for
the opportunity
um
yeah i also heard like tom cruise now
wants to go make a space movie
i just ugh anything with tom cruise no i
would follow tom cruise up in a rocket
you would uh he is he is literally my
like childhood crush and he still is
he's i know right he holds up um okay
well you've got the next story ruby so
please take it away i do so
i don't know if you've heard but
jennifer gardner posted this on her
instagram
she recently texted a selfie of herself
to a complete stranger
i mean i don't know about you but that's
happened to me before not a selfie but
you know personal information you're
embarrassed you know and her posting
that made me feel a little bit more you
know a little better about myself that
oh it's happened to jennifer gardner i'm
okay
you know it's happened like five times
to me though but it's wrong with me
i sent a video of myself to i know this
is gonna sound like a name drop it's not
she's my best friend since we were 14
and 16 cameron diaz and i sent her a
video and i happened to be changing in
my closet you couldn't see anything um
but then i start like moving the towel
around and just being like a complete
idiot
and um
i didn't go to her
it went to a boy named matthew
oh my god kindly was like um yeah it's
not cameron i think i have her old
number because i've gotten some other
stuff
for her
and then i was like oh god like i'm so
sorry and who are you and then i i kind
of got the sense that he was still in
high school yeah
all right well thank you so much that's
the news and we'll be right back
[Music]